This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. One of the most famous comedy sketches of the 20th century is built on a simple misunderstanding. We just pretend that we're organizing a baseball team here at the retired actors' home, and I am the manager. It's the routine from Abbott and Costello, who's on first. Well, let's see now, we have on our team, we have who's on first, what's on second, I don't know, who's on third.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。20世纪最著名的喜剧小品之一，其实建立在一个简单的误会上。我们只是假装在退休演员之家里组织一个棒球队，而我是经理。这是阿伯特和科斯特洛的经典段子，“谁在一垒”。好吧，让我们看看，我们队里有，一垒是“谁”，二垒是“什么”，我不知道在三垒。
That's what I want to find out. That's what I want to find out, the guy's name. I'm telling you, whoosan First, What's on second, I don't know's on third. That's what I want to find out. I have the guys' names. That's what I want to find out, the guys' names. I'm telling you, Hoosan First, What's on second, I don't know's on third. The duo first performed the sketch in the 1930s and continued to refine it over the next two decades. They rarely did it the same way twice. You learn a lot of guys' names at a baseball field.
这就是我想搞清楚的。这就是我想搞清楚的，那家伙的名字。我告诉你，谁在一垒，什么在二垒，我不知道在三垒。这就是我想搞清楚的。我知道那些家伙的名字。这就是我想搞清楚的，那些家伙的名字。我告诉你，谁在一垒，什么在二垒，我不知道在三垒。这个二人组在20世纪30年代首次表演了这个小品，并在接下来的二十年里不断完善它。他们很少用同样的方式表演两次。你在棒球场上能了解不少人的名字。
Well, go ahead, who's on first? Yes. I mean, the guys' names. Who? They got players first. Who? They got players first. Who? They got players first. Who's on first? Who's on first? Why do you mean the guys name. Who? They got play first. Who? They got play first best. Who?
好吧，说吧，谁在一垒？对。我是说，那些家伙的名字。谁？他们先让球员上。谁？他们先让球员上。谁？他们先让球员上。谁在一垒？谁在一垒？你为什么问我那个家伙的名字？谁？他们让球员先上。谁？他们让球员先上，最好是。谁？
They got a first best. Who's on first? Why do you ask me for? I don't know. That way, that way. Part of what makes the skit funny is that we are in on the joke. But what happens when the jokes on us? When real life conversations go off the rails
他们有个一垒手，最好是。谁在一垒？你问我干嘛？我不知道。那边，那边。这个小品好笑的一部分原因在于，我们都懂这个梗。但是当这个梗落到我们自己头上时会发生什么呢？当现实生活中的对话脱轨时
because of miscommunication or a misunderstanding, it's no laughing matter. There are so many things that could misfire the pace at which you speak, how you get to the point, the rhythms, the intonation patterns. Humor! That is a mind field. How do you let people know that you're joking and that you're teasing? This week on Hidden Brain,
因为沟通不畅或误解，这可一点也不好笑。有太多事情可能会出错——你说话的语速、你切入重点的方式、节奏、语调模式。幽默！那简直是一个雷区。你怎么让别人知道你在开玩笑、你在逗趣？本周的Hidden Brain，
we bring you the final installment of our Mind Reading 2.0 series. In earlier episodes, we've examined the ways we read other people's intentions. We've also looked at the social illusions that distort relationships. Today, in a favorite episode from 2021, we explore how clashing conversational styles
我们将为您带来“读心术2.0”系列的最后一期。在之前的节目中，我们探讨了我们解读他人意图的方式。我们还探讨了扭曲人际关系的社会幻觉。今天，在2021年的一期备受喜爱的节目中，我们将探讨冲突的对话风格
can lead to unnecessary conflict and how we can learn to talk and listen more effectively. You say tomato, I say tomato. If you travel abroad, you instinctively know that the customs in other countries are different. People have different ways of saying hello and goodbye. Different rules for conversations with friends. In recent decades, the linguist Deborah Tannen has discovered that many of us don't need to travel to exotic lands to experience the bewilderment and confusion of cross-cultural
如何导致不必要的冲突，以及我们如何学会更有效地交谈和倾听。你说是西红柿（tomato），我也说是西红柿（tomato）。如果你去国外旅行，你本能地知道其他国家的风俗习惯是不同的。人们有不同的问候和告别方式。与朋友交谈也有不同的规则。近几十年来，语言学家黛博拉·泰嫩发现，我们中的许多人其实不需要去异国他乡，就能体验到跨文化交流中的困惑和迷茫。
communication. We can experience those very same feelings when we talk to our own siblings, parents, partners, children, friends, and colleagues. She studies why this happens and how we can all have better conversations with the people in our lives. Deborah Tannen, welcome to Hidden Brain. Such a pleasure to be here. Thank you. You were born in Brooklyn, New York, your parents were immigrants, one from Poland,
当我们与自己的兄弟姐妹、父母、伴侣、孩子、朋友和同事交谈时，我们就会体验到完全相同的感受。她研究为什么会发生这种情况，以及我们如何才能与生活中的人进行更好的对话。黛博拉·泰嫩，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你。你出生在纽约布鲁克林，你的父母是移民，一个来自波兰，
one from Russia. They were both very alert to the ways people use language, but also alert to subtleties in human relationships. Can you tell me a little bit about the conversations you had at home and also the conversations you sometimes had about those conversations? Yes. Both told stories about people and also how people, things people had said and how people used language. My father, in particular, was really attuned to subtleties of language. And I remember one time he was telling me about an aunt that he had particularly liked.
一个来自俄罗斯。他们对人们使用语言的方式都非常敏锐，同时也对人际关系中的微妙之处很敏感。你能跟我讲讲你在家里进行的对话，以及你有时对这些对话进行的讨论吗？可以的。两人都讲过关于人的故事，也讲过人们、别人说过的话以及人们是如何使用语言的。尤其是我的父亲，对语言的微妙之处非常敏锐。我记得有一次他跟我讲起他特别喜欢的一个姑妈。
And he said, now there was this expression, Khas Fakhalila, something like heaven forbid. And he said, but she said Khalila Vahas. And he said, I remember it because nobody else said it that way. So he had that attunement to subtleties of language. And my mother was very interested in relationships. She was an electrologist, it's a removal of unwanted hair, and she would always be telling us about the stories her patients had told her that day, and so that combination of a two mental language and two relationships kind of came together for me.
他说，当时有这样一个表达，“Khas Fakhalila”，有点像“天哪”或“上帝保佑”。然后他说，但她说的是“Khalila Vahas”。他说，我记得这件事是因为没有别人会那样说。所以他对语言的微妙之处有着那样的敏锐度。而我的母亲对人际关系非常感兴趣。她是一名电解脱毛师，也就是去除不需要的毛发的工作，她总是给我们讲述她的病人们那天跟她讲的故事，因此这种对语言的敏锐和对人际关系的关注的结合，对我来说就融为一体了。
So yours later you grow up, you got married, your husband was Greek and you were living in Greece. You've written that your conversation styles were very different, especially when it came to being direct with one another. Can you give me an example or two of how this worked, Deborah? Yes, I would ask him a question, John's having a party and you want to go. And he would say something like, okay, now to me, okay, is not an answer. I want to go. I don't want to go. So I would say, are you sure you want to go? And he would say, why don't you make up your mind? No, where did that come from? And this is one that I actually went on and tested.
所以多年后你长大了，结了婚，你丈夫是希腊人，当时你们住在希腊。你曾写道，你们的对话风格非常不同，尤其是在彼此坦诚直率这一点上。黛博拉，你能举一两个例子说说这是怎么运作的吗？可以，我会问他一个问题：“约翰要办个派对，你想去吗？”他会说类似“好吧”这样的话。但在我看来，“好吧”并不是一个回答。我想去？我不想去？所以我就会问：“你确定你想去吗？”他会说：“你怎么就不能拿定主意呢？”不，这话是从哪儿来的？而且这是一个我后来真正去测试过的例子。
And sure enough, the Greeks that I interviewed and gave them this example were most likely to say the wife wouldn't ask unless she wanted to go and she wouldn't double check unless she wasn't happy with the decision. Debra was intrigued by the many ways people understood and misunderstood each other. Eventually, she returned to the United States
果不其然，我采访并向其提供这个例子的希腊人最有可能说的是：妻子如果不是想去就不会问，如果她对这个决定不满意，她就不会再三确认。黛博拉对人们相互理解和误解的种种方式很感兴趣。最终，她回到了美国，
and began a PhD in linguistics. One thanksgiving, she decided to do some research by recording a conversation with friends. I wonder how our parents felt about Thanksgiving. Two were from California, one was from the UK. Debra and two others were New Yorkers. It was simply my best friend, his brother, his former wife, and two of his friends who were in town.
并开始攻读语言学博士学位。感恩节那天，她决定通过录制与朋友的对话来做一些研究。我想知道我们的父母对感恩节有什么感觉。其中两人来自加利福尼亚，一人来自英国。黛博拉和其他两人是纽约人。这其实只是我最好的朋友、他的弟弟、他的前妻，以及当时在城的他的两个朋友。
Remember with WI and S2's to meet? No. They both had big, huge scotch burger there. No, it was that. We're ever big, huge, Scotch, perfect that. No. Where was that? Forever Center for Coincreacment for a place. Did they give you a picture? That's a lot of circle. That's a lot of circle.
记得Wi和S2是怎么见面的吗？不记得。他们俩都在那儿买了个超大的苏格兰汉堡。不对，是那个。我们总是有那种超级巨大的苏格兰……完美的那个。不对。那是哪儿？永远在宏伟改造中心（Center for Coincreacment）的一个地方。他们给了你一张照片吗？那是一个好大的圆圈。那是一个好大的圆圈。
Here's a lot of circle. It's a lot of circle. Now it's the only one. It's the only one. It's the only one. I don't know. And what I found, first of all, was that I could not study the conversational styles of each of the people
这里是一个好大的圆圈。这是一个好大的圆圈。现在这是唯一的一个了。这是唯一的一个。这是唯一的一个。我不知道。而我发现的第一件事是，我无法研究在场的每一个人的对话风格，
who was there because it was difficult for the Californians to get the floor. He's a sociologist who's so brilliant. He has to read. And it goes. And it goes. When you read it, you have to have a silence. All of them.
因为加州人很难插话。他是那种聪明绝顶的社会学家。他必须先阅读。然后继续。然后继续。当你阅读时，你必须保持沉默。所有人。
Read a silence. And I had to conclude that I was getting a chance to observe the conversational styles of the three New Yorkers, but not of the others, because they were not able to exercise their natural conversational styles. It's not that they never spoke, but they couldn't be part of the back and forth give and take, because any time anyone talks to anyone, we need a sense of how long a pause we think is normal between turns. And the New Yorker's sense of how long a pause was normal was shorter. And so while the Californians and even more the British women, while they were just waiting
都保持安静。我不得不得出结论，我有机会观察到的只是那三个纽约人的对话风格，而没有其他人的，因为他们无法展现自己自然的对话风格。并不是说他们从不说话，而是他们无法参与那种来回的互动，因为无论何时任何人与任何人交谈，我们都需要对“轮流说话之间我们认为正常的停顿是多长时间”有一个感知。而纽约人对正常停顿时间的感知更短。所以当加州人，甚至更甚之的英国女性，还在等待一个正常的停顿以便她们能插话时，
for a normal pause so that they could come in, One of the New Yorkers would get the sense, uh-oh, you know, they have nothing to say, we might as well film this pause. What's the analyze? There hasn't been one misunderstanding. We've all understood each other perfectly. What do you mean by that? I want to pause for a moment and just look at what you actually did as you were analyzing the conversation, because once you had this recording in hand, it took you two and a
其中一个纽约人就会觉得，糟糕，你知道的，他们没什么可说的，我们不妨把这段空白填满吧。分析什么呢？根本没有发生误解。我们彼此完全理解对方。你这话是什么意思？我想暂停一会儿，看看你在分析对话时到底做了什么，因为一旦你拿到了这段录音，你花了两个半月的时间来转录这段三小时的对话。你试图捕捉多少细节？我想捕捉我所意识到、所感知到的一切。所以我在转录中做了笔记，记录一个人说的是“the”还是“the”（不同发音），我还用秒表测量了有明显停顿的词与词之间的秒数。我还让参与过对话的人对它进行核对，
half months to transcribe this three-hour conversation. How much detail were you trying to capture? I wanted to capture everything that I was aware of that I had perceived. So I made notes in the transcription whether whether a person said, the or the, but I had a stopwatch and measured the number of seconds between words when it was a perceptible pause. And I had it checked by the people who had been part of the conversation,
他们听了录音并帮我核对。我在这里发现的真正深刻且非凡之处在于，你实际上付出了那种程度的细心、精确和细节，才真正意识到对话表面之下正在发生着某些事情——也就是人们说特定话语的方式。黛博拉，你从中得出的见解是什么
they listened to it and checked it for me. What I find really insightful and remarkable here is that it actually took that level of care and precision and detail for you to actually realize that there was something happening beneath the surface of the conversation, the way people said certain things. What was the insight that you took away Debra
关于对话风格如何影响对话的展开以及人们如何看待彼此？嗯，其中一个见解是，你必须更深入地观察，才能看出意图是什么，以及一个人的说话方式实际上是如何受到另一个人说话方式的影响的。有些人可能会下结论说纽约人在打断别人，因为当别人在说话时他们就开始说话了。嗯，有时我们同时说话是为了表现出热情。我们太感兴趣了。我们不会等你停下来。我们边听边说。我本该和你们这样的。
about the ways in which conversational styles affected how conversations unfolded and how people perceived one another. Well, one of the insights is that you have to look more deeply to see what the intentions were and how the way one person speaks is actually influenced by how another person speaks. Some people might have concluded the New Yorkers are interrupting because they're starting to talk when someone else is speaking. Well, sometimes we talk along as a way of showing enthusiasm. We're so interested. We don't wait for you to stop. We talk along. I should have had with you guys.
对，我们一起说的。没错。我们一起说的。我当时就像一个人。我们本该，我们本该，我们本该……（重复省略）如果我们和认为“一次只能有一个声音说话”的人这样做，如果你在我说话时开始说话，那就意味着你在打断我，而我会停下来。那么，是谁造成了这种打断呢？这需要两个人，一个开始，另一个停止。纽约人风格的另一个方面。确保其他人能插话并不是发言者的工作。你可能会说这是一种尊重。如果别人想插话，你信任他们会自己找到机会。
Yeah, we did together. That's right. We did together. I was like a person. We should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should have, we should If we do that with someone who thinks one voice goes at a time, if you begin speaking while I'm speaking, that means you're interrupting and I'll stop. Well, who created that interruption? It took two people, someone to start and someone to stop. Another aspect of the style of the New Yorkers. It isn't the job of a speaker to make sure that other people get the floor. Can you might say it's a sign of respect. You trust other people to get the floor if they want.
因此，如果有人试图提起一个话题而其他人正在说话，并且他们没有停下来听，这个人会再试一次。如果还是没人接话，他们会再试一次。我们该这么做吗？我们应该从我们要玩的这种方式开始吗？你得到答案了吗？好吧。
And so if someone tried to bring up a topic and others were speaking and they didn't stop for them, they would try again. And if it still wasn't picked up, they would try again. Should we do that? Should we start with the way we're about to play? Did you get the answer? OK.
他听见了吗？我们说过“board girl board”（滑板女孩滑板/无聊女孩无聊）。Board girl board。你听说过那个被问到的女士吗？有一个例子是这样的，其中一个纽约人——不是他——尝试了七次，才终于轮到他说出他想说的话。加州人可不会那样做。如果他们试图说些什么却没人接话，他们就放弃了。你在那段录音中注意到你自己的对话风格了吗，
Did he hear it? We have said board girl board. Board girl board. Did you hear about the lady who was asked? And there was one example where one of the New Yorkers, it wasn't he, tried seven times before he got his turn to say what he wanted to say. The Californians wouldn't do that. If they tried to say something and it wasn't picked up, they gave up. Did you notice things about your own conversational style in that recording
因为这可能是你第一次真正放慢速度，听自己说话？是的，是的。我注意到了。在某些情况下，当我看到自己说话方式产生的影响时，甚至感到有些尴尬。这其中的一个例子就是我最终称之为“机关枪式提问”的现象。当时我在和我的朋友卡尔交谈，他是我最好的朋友，但其中一位客人是他的一个朋友，从洛杉矶来做客。名字叫查克。所以我试图对查克表现得友好，让他在这里感到受欢迎。所以事实是，我对这些问题答案心知肚明，因为卡尔已经告诉我了，但我只是想对查克好一点，给他一个发言的机会。然后对话大概是这样的。我说：“你是从洛杉矶来的？”
because for the first time, probably you were actually slowing down and listening to yourself speak? Yes, yes. I did. And in some cases, was kind of embarrassed when I saw the effect of my ways of speaking. An example of that is what I ended up calling machine gun questions. So I was talking to my friend Carl, he's my best friend, but one of the guests was a friend of his who was visiting from Los Angeles. The name was Chuck. So I was trying to be friendly to Chuck and make him feel welcome here. So the truth is I knew the answers to these questions because Carly told me, but I was trying to be nice to Chuck and give him the floor. And the conversation went something like this. I said, you're from LA?
“你住在洛杉矶吗？是的。你来这里旅游吗？你在那里做什么？你在那里做什么？”“我在迪士尼博物馆工作。”“你是作家？艺术家？”
You live in LA? Yeah. You're visiting here? What do you do there? What do you do there? I work at Disney Museum. You're a writer? Artists?
“对，没错。我是广告文案。”一个接一个，伴随着他高亢、急促的句法，当我听录音时，我意识到这产生了与我预期完全相反的效果。他没有接话，也没有多说，事后我和他谈过这件事。我和所有在场的这些人至今都保持着联系。
Yeah, right. I'm advertising copy. It was one after another, and his high pitch, Cliped syntax, and when I listened to the tape, I realized it was having the opposite effect of what I expected. He wasn't taking the floor and he wasn't talking, and I talked to him about it afterwards. I'm still in touch with all these people who were there.
他只是被我连珠炮似的问题打了个措手不及。所以那是你的永久全职工作吗？所以你吃饭？是的。感觉他就像是被机枪扫射了一样。不仅没有退缩，反而还降档减速？我却抛出了越来越多这样的问题：“你找到那份工作了吗？”
He was just caught off guard by the rapidity of my questions. So was that to a permanent full-time thing you had? So you eat? Yeah. It seemed like he was being assaulted by machine gunfire. And instead of backing off Did you go there for that purpose and downshifting? I was putting on more and more of these questions Did you get that job?
我爸爸1937年圣诞节的……所以这里有趣的地方在于，如果你和某人分享一种对话风格，你基本上可以玩这种游戏，换句话说，你可以用非常快速的机关枪式交流打断对话的流畅度，而双方都不会认为这很讨厌或很粗鲁。但是，如果你没有相同的对话风格，那么同样的打断就会被认为
My dad's for Christmas 1937 So the interesting thing there is that if you share a conversational style with someone You essentially can play this game where in in other words, you can interrupt the flow of a conversation with sort of very quick machine gun exchanges, and neither party thinks of it as being obnoxious or rude. But if you don't share the same conversational styles, then the very same interruption can come across
是完全不同的，很显然在感恩节晚宴上，其中一些情况确实发生了。绝对是的。而且顺便说一句，这种相互的负面印象是双向的。不仅是以“边听边说来表现热情”的人冒着被视为粗鲁的风险，那些坐在那里却在对话中不尽职的人，
as being completely different, clearly over the Thanksgiving dinner, some of that was happening. Absolutely. And by the way, these mutual and negative impressions go both ways. It isn't only the ones who are talking along to show enthusiasm run the risk of being seen as rude, but people who sit there and don't do their part
同样也会给人以粗鲁的印象。这确实是关于人际关系和对话风格的一个普遍规律。如果你和一个与你有相同对话风格的人交谈，你的说话方式对你来说是有意义的，对他们来说也是有意义的。这不仅在于他们不认为你粗鲁，还在于他们欣赏你欣赏他们的方式。这就像是一种“我们懂彼此”的信号。
in the conversation, that also comes across as rude. And this is really a universal about human relations and about conversational style. If you talk to someone who shares a conversational style with you, you just talk in a way that to you make sense, it makes sense to them. And it isn't only that they don't think you're rude. It's that they appreciate the way you are appreciating them. It is like a sign of we get each other.
这是一次很棒的对话。一场完美契合的对话是理智的愿景，它让人安心，确信你是个对的人，一切都在表面之下顺利展开。我们许多人并未意识到这些隐藏的对话。这些事情是如此自动化，以至于当事情开始出错时，我们不会去那个层面寻找原因。你不会走开然后说，你不会看出区别。
This is a great conversation. A perfectly tuned conversation is a vision of sanity, a reassurance that you are a right sort of person and all is unfolding beneath the surface. Lots of us are not aware of these hidden conversations. These things are so automatic that when things start to go wrong, we don't look at that level. You don't walk away, say, you're not going to be able to see the difference.
你不会看出区别。这些事情是如此自动化，以至于当事情开始出错时，我们不会去那个层面寻找原因。你不会走开然后说，你知道，刚才有点尴尬，因为我觉得你期望的停顿时间比我短一毫秒。你走开时会说，你就是那种人，你知道的，你不想给我说话的机会，或者你只想听你自己说话，反之亦然。为什么我跟你说话就像拔牙一样？你曾在某个地方写道，由对话风格差异导致的误解之所以
You're not going to be able to see the difference. These things are so automatic that when things start to go wrong, we don't look at that level. You don't walk away saying, you know, that was kind of awkward because I think you expect a millisecond short of pause than I do. You walk away saying the kind of person you are, you know, you didn't want to give me a chance to talk or you only want to hear yourself talk or the other side. Why do I have, is the conversation with you like pulling teeth? You write at one point what makes misunderstandings resulting from conversational style differences
如此难以消除，是因为我们没有谈论它们的方式。我们不会说“当我的声音有这种特质时，意思是我是友好的”。此类信号是自动发送和感知的。我要补充的是，它们很可能是无意识地发送和感知的。如果你和我没有使用关于“停顿意味着什么”、“某种语气意味着什么”的同一本密码本，我们可能会不断地误解对方，尽管我们双方都怀着最好的善意。
so hard to clear up is that we don't have a way of talking about them. We don't think of saying when my voice has that quality, it means I'm being friendly. Such cues are sent and perceived automatically. And I might add, they're probably sent and perceived unconsciously. If you and I are not using the same code book about what a pause means, what a certain tone means, we might constantly misunderstand one another, even though both of us have the best of intentions.
是的，令人震惊的是，我的意思是，这种情况甚至发生在那些结婚、同居或彼此非常了解的人之间。这里有另一个关于终身朋友的例子。我想此时他们已经80多岁了，从十几岁起就是朋友。他们绕着一个湖散步，其中一个人在倾述一件让她担忧的事情。然后一只母鸭带着她的小鸭子顺着湖面游了过来。
Yes, and astonishingly, I mean, this even happens among people who are married to each other, are lived together or know each other very well. So here's another example of lifelong friends. I think at this point, they're in their 80s, and they've been friends since they were teens. They were walking along around a lake, and one was telling about something that was, she was concerned about. And then there's a duck coming along the lake with her little ducklings behind her.
注意到这一幕的那个人说：“哦，看那只鸭子，多迷人啊！”她的朋友却说：“你根本没在听我说话。”她回答说：“我当然在听你说话。你为什么会觉得我没在听你说话呢？”“那你在谈论鸭子干嘛？”当我们回来时，这些误解如何在人际关系中造成深深的创伤，以及如何阻止人们获得其实触手可及的幸福。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
And the one who notices it, oh, look at that duck, isn't that charming? And her friend said, you're not listening to me. And she said, of course I'm listening to you. Why would you think, I'm not listening to you? Well, why are you talking about the ducks? When we come back, how these misunderstandings produce deep wounds in relationships and keep people from the happiness that is actually within their reach. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。黛博拉·泰嫩是乔治城大学的语言学家。她著有近十本书，探讨人们如何相互交谈以及对话中如何产生误解。在她职业生涯的早期，她发现许多此类误解都是无意的。我认为你在表达一些你并未表达的意思，因为在不知不觉中，我们有着不同的对话风格或不同的心理取向。黛博拉，许多学者的作品都在会议上发表过，其中一些人还写书。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Debra Tanen is a linguist at Georgetown University. She is the author of nearly a dozen books about how people talk to one another and the ways in which misunderstandings arise in conversation. Early in her career, she discovered that many of these misunderstandings were unintentional. I think you're saying something that you're not saying because without being aware of it, we have different styles of conversation or different psychological orientations. Deborah, lots of academics get their work presented at conferences, some of them write books.
你做过这些，但你还拥有一个受你的创意启发而制作的电视节目。对于不熟悉这个节目的年轻观众或海外听众，你能跟我们讲讲《家居装饰》（Home Improvement）的设定吗？可以，《家居装饰》是一部情景喜剧，讲的是一个有点像杂务工类型的男人，他和妻子有着某种关系。每当他们发生争吵时——他们经常吵架，各个片段的设定都是他们发生了某种争吵，他就会走到后院，
You've done those things, but you also had a TV show inspired by your ideas. For our younger or overseas listeners who are not familiar with this show, can you tell us the premise of home improvement? Yes, home improvement was a situation comedy, a man who's kind of a handyman type, and he's got a relationship with his wife. And then whenever they have arguments, which they have often, the premise of the individual segments is some argument they have, he would go out in the backyard
隔着栅栏跟邻居倾诉，而邻居则会开解这些争吵，制作和创造这个节目的制作人实际上亲口告诉我，邻居的建议正是取材自我的书。该死，该死，该死，成就伟大的第一步是保持谦逊。哦，是啊，是啊。也许你不该试图掌握所有答案，而是应该多问问题。
and talk over the fence to his neighbor, and the neighbor would shed light on these arguments, and it was actually told to me by the people who produced and created the show, the neighbor's advice came out of my books. Damn, damn, damn, the first step for greatness is humbling yourself. Oh yeah, oh yeah. Maybe you shouldn't try to have all the answers and instead ask more questions.
你看，蒂姆，一个真正智者的问题总是多于答案。黛博拉，我想放给你听另一段《家居装饰》的剪辑。妻子吉尔准备了一场惊喜的浪漫晚餐。她打电话让他回家。他说他15分钟内回来。但他最后却和朋友在酒吧待了整晚。当他回家时，发生了以下这一幕。
You see, Tim, a truly wise man always has more questions than answers. Debra, I want to play you another clip from Home Improvement. Jill, who's the wife, has prepared a surprise romantic dinner. She gets on the phone and asks him to come home. He says he'll be back in 15 minutes. But he ends up staying the whole evening at a bar with his friends. Here's what happens when he comes home.
我真的很抱歉，但那家伙对人际关系之类的事情进行了一些非常认真的讨论，你知道的。男人、女人、各种事情、分享感受。挺沉重的话题。笑声我花了整整两天来策划今晚。你知不知道我们有多久没有一起度过一个安静、浪漫的夜晚了？我一接电话你就说，回家。
I'm really sorry, but the guy's not gotten some real serious discussions about relationship things, you know. Men, women, stuff, sharing feelings. Pretty heavy stuff. LAUGHTER I spent two days planning this evening. Do you have any idea how long it's been since we had a quiet, romantic evening together? I was on the phone once you said, come home.
我想给你个惊喜。晚安。得了吧，吉尔。我不跟这些……说过回家。我想给你个惊喜。晚安。得了吧，吉尔。我不是每天晚上都跟这些家伙出去。是什么让你这么生气？我很生气，因为你说你15分钟内到家，结果你却去工作了。因为我在电话里疯狂地调情。
I wanted to surprise you. Good night. Come on, Jill. I don't go out with these said, come home. I want it to surprise you. Good night. Come on, Jill. I don't go out with these guys every night. What's making you so angry? I am angry because you said you're going to be home in 15 minutes and then you worked. Because I'm flirting with you like crazy on the phone.
你甚至都没注意到。最重要的是，我费了这么大劲却白忙一场。我一个人过了一整晚。现在你只能面对一盘冷掉的食物了。别担心我。我在酒吧吃过了。黛博拉，来剖析一下刚刚发生了什么吧。我认为问题可以追溯到那通电话，她觉得她用自己特有的方式向他传达了她在调情，她试图营造一种浪漫的氛围，却没有直接告诉他“回家，我为你准备了惊喜”或者“你今晚回家真的很重要”。他说，15分钟内到家。好吧。她信以为真了。这真是女性和男性之间非常普遍的文化差异。
You didn't even notice. And most of all, because I went to all this trouble for nothing. I spent the whole evening by myself. And now you're stuck with a plate of cold food. I don't worry about me. I ate at the bar. So unpack what just happened here, Deborah. I think the trouble could be traced to the conversation where she feels that she communicated in her way
如果你把女性和男性的说话方式视为文化差异，他期望他的妻子直接告诉他，因此他的天线并没有用来捕捉那些暗示。他觉得自己被错误指责了：“你没告诉我有什么特殊原因让我必须回家，那我怎么会知道？你难道指望我成会读心术吗？”
of speaking to him that she was flirting, that she was trying to set up a romantic atmosphere, and then didn't tell him directly, come home, I have a surprise for you, or it's really important you come home tonight. He said, it'll be home in 15 minutes. Fine. She took a matter's word. And this is such a common cultural difference between women and men.
这有什么特殊原因吗？那我怎么会知道？你难道指望我成会读心术吗？我们之前也讨论过这个问题，也就是倾向于直接说话的人和倾向于使用更间接说话的人之间的区别。你有一个叫做“生日礼物常规”的概念，很好地说明了这一点。那是什么？倾向于
If you think of women's and men's ways of speaking as cultural differences He expected that his wife would just tell him directly and so his antenna We're not rolled out for picking up those hints And he feels falsely accused you didn't tell me there was this special reason for me to come home So how could I know what do you expect me to be a mindread? reason for me to come home. So how could I know? What do you expect me to be a mind reader? And we talked about this earlier as well, sort of the difference between people who prefer their speech to be direct and people who prefer to use more indirect speech. You have something called the birthday present routine that illustrates this idea. What is it? People who tend to
直接表达的人不明白为什么有人要拐弯抹角，但有时如果你想想生日礼物的例子，你就能理解了。你希望你爱的人和爱你的人送你一份你真正想要的生日礼物，因为这是一种爱的信号，表明他们在乎你，愿意花心思去琢磨该送你什么，表明他们足够了解你，能挑出对的东西。现在，你可能会说，“好吧，你为什么不直接告诉他们你想要什么呢？那就能保证你得到你想要的东西。”
be direct don't understand why anyone be indirect, but sometimes they can understand it if you think of the birthday present it seems. You want the person you love and who loves you to give you a birthday present that you would want because it's a sign that they care, that they are willing to take the trouble to figure out what to get you, that they know you well enough to pick the right thing. Now, you could say, well, why don't you just tell them what you want? That would guarantee that you get what you want.
你可能会得到你想要的东西，但你得不到所有其他你想要的东西。那是他们在乎的证据，是他们足够了解你、知道你会想要什么的证据。这就是间接表达在其他语境下的运作方式。我认为指出这一点非常重要：首先，这并不总是关乎男女。而在与我丈夫的对话中，我反而是那个更倾向于直接表达的人。他反而是那个更倾向于间接表达的人。
You might get what you want, but you don't get all those other things that you want. Evidence that they care, evidence that they know you well enough to know what you would want. And so that is how indirectness works in other contexts as well. And I think it's so important to point out, first of all, it's not always women and men. And in the conversations with my husband, I was the one who was more likely to be direct. He was the one more likely to be indirect.
所以这里面有很多文化差异、地域差异、种族差异以及各种其他影响。我们表达心意的方式看起来是那么地理所当然，以至于你真的必须学会退后一步说：“我爱这个人，他/她会不会是在使用一种不同的风格呢？”我们认为，由于我们说的是同一种语言，而且我们彼此相爱、互相喜欢或者我们是亲戚，我们就应该互相理解。当亲密关系中的误解由于这些潜在的沟通风格差异而产生时，有时会向双方传递一个巨大的信号：这段关系出问题了。黛博拉提到了她在现实生活中听到的一个例子：一对夫妻在车里开车。
So there's a lot of cultural differences, regional differences, ethnic differences, all kinds of other influences. The way we say what we mean seems so obviously the way to do it, that you really have to learn to step back and say, could this person that I love be using a different style? We think that because we speak the same language and we think
她对他说：“你渴吗，杰罗？你想停下来喝一杯吗？”他并不渴，所以他说不。
because we love each other or we like each other or we're relatives, we should understand each other. When misunderstandings arise in closed relationships as a result of these underlying differences in communication styles, it can sometimes send a big message to both parties. This relationship isn't working. Deborah mentions a real life example she heard of a couple driving in a car. And she had said to him, are you thirsty, Jero? Would you like to stop for a drink? And he wasn't, so he said no.
后来事实证明她很恼火，因为她自己其实想停下来。而他的感觉，有点像《家居装饰》里的那个例子，是：她为什么不直接告诉我？她为什么跟我玩心理游戏？为什么我非得会读心术不可？我说：“你知道的，我猜当你的妻子说‘你渴吗？你想停下来喝一杯吗？’时，她可能并没有期望得到一个简单的‘是’或‘否’的回答。她可能期望听到类似‘我不知道，你觉得呢？’这样的话，然后她就可以说‘我不知道，你觉得呢？’”
And then later it turned out that she was annoyed because she had wanted to stop. And his feeling, kind of like the home-improving example, was, why didn't she tell me? Why does she play games with me? Why do I have to be a mind reader? And I said, you know, I suspect that when your wife said, are you thirsty? Would you like to stop for a drink? She probably was not expecting a yes-no answer. She probably expected something like, I don't know, how do you feel about it? And then she could say, I don't know, how do you
她传达的意思是她不想强人所难，她想知道他的感受如何。现在，为什么她会觉得她必须那样做，而他却不这么认为呢？我猜他的风格是：你可以直接提出你的想法，如果我不喜欢，我会告诉你。所以你是从具体的事情开始，然后逐渐展开。而其他人——她似乎就是这种人——你是从模糊的开始，然后逐渐深入。你引用了人类学家格雷戈里·贝特森（Gregory Bateson）的话，他谈到了“信息”和“元信息”（meta-message）。你能向我解释一下这些术语吗？可以。信息是字面词语的意思。元信息则是关于人际关系的暗示——即你在这种语境下、以这种方式说出这些话，反映了你们是怎样的一种关系。通常，我们最终会为字面信息争吵不休，而真正让我们心烦意乱的其实是元信息。
feel about it? She was communicating that she didn't want to make a demand, she wanted to know how it would be with him. Now, why would she think she has to do that and why would he not think so? My guess is that his style says you can just throw out my deal and if I don't like it, I'll tell you. So you start specific and you work your way out. Other people, and she seems to be one who does it this way, you start vague and work your way in. You cite the anthropologist Gregory Bateson, who talks about something called the message and the meta-message. Can you explain those terms to me? Yes. The message is the meaning of the words. The meta-message is what it says about the relationship that you say these words in
我和我的一个同事走在一起，那是大学校园里的一位女同事，还有我们的一位年长男同事卡斯特拉·帕斯（Krastra Path），那是东北部秋高气爽的一天，她对他说：“嗨，你的外套呢？”他说：“谢谢妈妈。”然后等她走开后，她有点纳闷地说：“那是什么意思？”她问“你的外套在哪儿”的元信息是什么？对她而言，这传递的是友好的元信息，如果你对一个人的健康状况说点什么，你知道的，这表现出对他们的另一层关心。
this way, in this context. Often, we end up arguing about the message when it's the meta-message that upset us. I was walking with a colleague of mine, woman on college campus, and one of our older male colleagues, Krastra Path, and it was one of these brisk fall days in the Northeast and she said to him, hi, where's your coat? And he said, thanks mom. And then as she walked away, she kind of said, what was that about? What was the meta-message of her asking, where's your coat? For her, it was a meta-message of her asking where is your code? For her it was a meta-message of friendliness, and if you say something about a person's welfare, you know, that shows another level of caring about them.
而他回应的则是这样一种元信息：这是母亲对孩子说话的方式，或者是处于权威地位的人对下属说话的方式。这指出了另一个经常出现在女性和男性之间的动态——当然这也可能发生在你我任何两个人之间。每当我们交谈时，我们都必须平衡两件事：谁处于上位、谁处于下位，以及我们是亲近还是疏远？
He responded to the meta-message that this is a way of mother talks to a child, or a person in a position of authority, that talks just a subordinate. It points up another dynamic that often comes up with women and men who again can come up between any two people. Anytime we talk to each other, we have to balance both who's up, who's down, and are we closer distant?
通常女性在结束一段对话时会问：“这让我们更亲近了吗？还是把我们推得更远了？”而男性则更有可能回应这个问题：“这把我们中的一个置于上位还是下位了？”这方面的例子有很多，比如一个妻子感到很受伤，因为她丈夫打电话来说：“我有个朋友，我高中的朋友来镇上了。我今晚要跟他一起吃晚饭。”她就说：“天哪，你知道的，也许我有一些安排，你为什么不问问这会如何影响我的安排呢？”
And often women will walk away from a conversation asking, did this bring us closer? We'll push this farther apart, where men are more likely to respond to the question, did this put one of us in a one-up or a one-down position? And there's so many examples of that, a woman who was hurt that her husband called up and said, I have a friend, my high school friend is in town. I'm gonna have dinner with him tonight. And she said, gee, you know, maybe I had some plants and I why don't you ask how that's gonna affect my plants.
而他说：“我总不能告诉我的朋友，我需要征得我妻子同意吧。”现在，跟你的妻子、你的配偶、与你同住的人核对一下，这难道是关于“征得许可”吗？谁上谁下，还是关于“建立连接”？我们的所作所为会互相影响，所以我们会对诸如此类的事情进行协商。所以你写道，女性和男性沟通风格的种子是在他们成长过程中学习使用语言的方式中播下的，即使我们在同一个家庭长大，我们也是在不同的世界中长大的。你这话是什么意思？
And he said, I can't tell my friend, I need to ask my wife for permission. Now, it's checking with your wife, your spouse, the person you live with, is this about permission? Who's up who's down, or is it about connection? What we do affects each other, and so we negotiate things like that. So you write that the seeds of women's and men's style are sewn in the ways they learn to use language while growing up, and that we grow up in different worlds, even when we grow up in the same household. What do you mean by that?
男孩和女孩倾向于在各自性别的独立群体中玩耍。他们社交的方式、小女孩和小男孩使用语言和游戏的方式往往是不同的。现在，这是由研究儿童玩耍的心理学家和人类学家研究所证实的。他们观察到，女孩倾向于在较小的群体中玩耍，通常是一对一，她们的社交生活通常
Boys and girls tend to play in sex-separate groups. And the ways that they socialize, the way little girls and little boys use language and play, tends to be different. Now, this is researched by psychologists, anthropologists, that have studied kids at play. And they have observed that girls tend to play in smaller groups, often one-on-one, their social life often,
集中在一个最好的朋友身上。她们花很多时间坐在一起聊天。通常是讲秘密。我收集了来自世界各地的照片。两个小女孩，一个在另一个耳边低语。我确实见过一些小男孩这样做的照片，但不多。男孩倾向于在更大的群体中玩耍，
focused on a best friend. They spend a lot of time sitting and talking. Often it's telling secrets. I collect pictures from, again, all over the world. Two little girls, one is whispering in the other's ear. I have encountered a few pictures of boys doing that, but not many. Boys tend to play in larger groups,
并且活动是核心。你最好的朋友就是那个和你一起做所有事的人。玛乔丽·哈尼特·古德曼（Marjorie Harnett Goodman）是加州大学洛杉矶分校的人类学家，她观察到了这一点。男孩经常会告诉其他男孩该做什么。这让他们在群体中获得地位——那个指挥别人做事、别人又听从他的人就是领袖。
and it's the activity that's central. Your best friend is the one you do everything with. Marjorie Harnett's Goodman is an anthropologist at UCLA who has observed this. That boys will often tell the other boys what to do. And that gives them status in the group, the one who tells the others what to do, and they listen, he's the leader.
如果女孩指挥其他女孩做事，她就会被认为是专横的，大家就不想跟她玩了。当然，所有这一切对于你成年后、尤其是在工作世界中，都有着重大的意义。我从中得出的更大结论是，我们所有人都是在某些特定的文化世界中成长的。这些世界往往就像鱼儿身处的水一样，
If girls tell other girls what to do, she's bossy and they don't want to play with her. And all of this, of course, has great implications for when your adults, especially in the world of work. The larger thing that I'm taking away from this is that all of us grow up in certain specific cultural worlds. And we're often those worlds I like, the water we swim in, if we're fish.
我是说，这些世界是我们甚至注意不到的。我们某种程度上假设整个世界一定和我们成长的世界一模一样。我们幼稚地假设其他人也拥有与我们相同的文化背景和文化世界观。因此，大量的沟通不畅也由此产生。比如你曾谈到，当人们结婚时，他们想象他们的伴侣会成为
I mean, their worlds we don't even notice. We sort of assume that the entire world must be like the world in which we grew up. And we sort of naively assume that others share our cultural backgrounds and cultural worldviews. And so much miscommunication happens because of that. You've talked, for example, about how when people get married, they imagine that their partners are going to be,
你知道的，他们一生中拥有过的所有最好朋友的“升级加强版”。当然，这给那段新的关系带来了沉重的负担。是的，是的，我经常说，对于女孩和女性来说，交谈是维系她们关系的纽带。所以她们期望，如果她们是异性恋，她们会期望他会成为最好朋友的一个崭新且改进的版本。他会把一切都告诉她。
you know, better versions of all of the best friends they've had throughout the rest of their lives. And of course, that places significant burden on that new relationship. Yes, yes, I often say that for girls and women, talk is the glue that holds their relationship together. And so they expect that when they, if they're heterosexual and they expect he's going to be a new and improved version of a best friend. He's going to tell me everything.
你知道，这是他们一生中所有最好朋友的更好版本。当然，这给那段新关系带来了沉重的负担。是的，是的，我经常说，对于女孩和女人来说，倾诉是维持她们关系的纽带。因此，她们期望，当她们（如果是异性恋）时，她们期望他将成为一个全新且改良版的最好朋友。他会把一切都告诉我。
And then you get to the end of the day and he comes home and she tells him what happened and what she did and who she talked to and what they said and what's that made her think and what that made her feel and then how was your day? Say, well, rap race. Really didn't anything happen? Nope. And then they go out to dinner and they're having dinner with a number of other couples and suddenly he's regaling the dinner party with something
然后你到了了一天的末尾，他回到家，她告诉他发生了什么、她做了什么、她和谁聊过、他们说了什么、这让她想到了什么、这让她有什么感受，接着问：“你今天过得怎么样？”他说：“嗨，老样子。真的有什么事发生吗？”“没有。”然后他们出去吃晚饭，和好几对其他夫妇一起吃晚饭，突然间他开始在晚宴上眉飞色舞地讲着
that happened during the day and she feels hurt. You know, what am I, top liver? Why didn't you tell me this? And it seems to really be a different sense of the place of talking a relationship. So for many, and guys, and I always feel uncomfortable saying women men, when nothing is true of all women and men, we have so many other influences on our style. But often men feel like just being together is what matters. So we can be not talking to each other
白天发生的事，她感到很受伤。你知道的，我是什么局外人吗？为什么你没告诉我这个？这似乎真的是对谈话在关系中地位的一种截然不同的理解。所以对许多人——伙计们，每当我把女人和男人相提并论时我总是感到不自在，因为没有一概而论适用于所有女人和男人，我们的风格受到的其他影响太多了。但男人通常觉得，只要待在一起就是最重要的。所以我们可以互不说话
and yet we're together, and that's great. So it's a kind of public speaking and private speaking. From his point of view, when he's out with a group, he has to do his part, you know, make sure he gets the attention and the respect that he deserves. And it's a kind of display. And here's when talk comes into its own. For many women, you know, when you're out in public, you kind of have to be careful what you say.
但我们依然在一起，那就很棒了。所以这是一种公共发言和私人发言。在他看来，当他和一群人在一起时，他必须尽到自己的本分，你知道的，确保他得到他应得的关注和尊重。这是一种展示。而这正是谈话大显身手的时候。对许多女人来说，你知道的，当你在公共场合时，你得小心你说的话。
If you talk too much, people think you talk too much. You might say the wrong thing. You might offend somebody. Now you're home, but someone you're close to, you feel comfortable, you're free to talk. I'm wondering, as you go through life, I mean, obviously you notice these things happening with other people. Do you notice this happening in your own life, Deborah? Do you notice moments where you basically stop and say, uh-oh, I understand I miss the
如果你说得太多，人们会觉得你说得太多。你可能会说错话。你可能会冒犯某人。现在你回家了，和你亲近的人在一起，你感到自在，你可以畅所欲言。我在想，随着你经历人生，我的意思是，很显然你注意到这些事情发生在其他人身上。黛博拉，你注意到这些事情也发生在你的生活中吗？你是否注意到某些时刻，你基本上会停下来，然后说，“哦哦，我明白了，我错过了
meta message of what was being communicated here? Well, I tell you one thing that comes to mind. This is before I was married, so it was a fellow I was dating at the time. And we were having an argument. The phone rang, somebody called and said, turn on the television, you're on the television right now. So we interrupt our argument, turn on the television, you're on the television right now. So we interrupt our argument, put on the television, and there I was being interviewed
这里所交流内容的元信息？”嗯，我告诉你一件我想到的事。这是在我结婚前，所以我当时正在和一个男生约会。我们当时正在争吵。电话响了，有人打来电话说，打开电视，你们现在就在电视上。于是我们打断争吵，打开电视，你们现在就在电视上。所以我们打断争吵，打开电视，然后我正在接受采访
about conversationalist dialogue. And what did you find out about conversation after listening to Wolf? And I was holding forth on something that was quite similar to what we were arguing about. So what's the answer in 10 seconds or less? Understand that there are conversational style differences and sometimes the adversarial approach is not going to be the best one.
关于对话式的对话。听了沃尔夫的话后，你对对话有什么发现？当时我正在滔滔不绝地谈论一些东西，这和我们刚才争吵的内容非常相似。那么在10秒或更短的时间内答案是什么？理解对话风格存在差异，有时对抗性的方法并不是最好的方法。
And did he turn to you and say, Debra Tannen, could you listen to Debra Tannen? We just both laughed, it was so funny. Much of the time, misunderstandings don't end in laughter. They don't even end in outbursts of anger, especially when it comes to friends or colleagues, we are hesitant to bring up misunderstandings. We let them go, or we say we let them go, but they fester. Debra recalls an incident like this. After she remarried, she and her husband had two friends over for dinner one night.
他有没有转向你然后说：“黛博拉·坦宁，你能听听黛博拉·坦宁的话吗？”我们俩只是大笑，太好笑了。大多数时候，误解并没有以笑声结束。它们甚至没有以爆发的愤怒结束，特别是当涉及到朋友或同事时，我们对提起误解感到犹豫。我们放任不管，或者说我们放任不管，但它们却在心里溃烂。黛博拉回忆起了一次这样的经历。她再婚后，有一天晚上她和丈夫请了两个朋友来家里吃晚饭。
A friend had come over and another friend of my husband's was there as well. And my friend, her name was Tamara, kept offering to help. So when we were serving appetizers, she would help out by kind of offering people appetizers. And when it came to cleaning up, she was helping to clean up. And I kept telling her, no you're the guest, you know, you stay here, but she kept doing it anyway. And at one point I was so frustrated, I actually grabbed her by the arm and popped her down, but she was up and trying to help watch the dishes.
有个朋友来了，我丈夫的另一个朋友也在那儿。我的朋友，她叫塔玛拉，不停地提出帮忙。所以当我们端上开胃菜时，她会通过向大家提供开胃菜来帮忙。到了清理的时候，她也在帮忙打扫。我一直告诉她，不，你是客人，你知道的，你呆在这里，但她还是不停地做。有一次我太沮丧了，我居然抓住她的胳膊把她按坐下来，但她还是站起来试图帮忙洗盘子。
And I was so put off by it that I actually found myself thinking, I'm not sure I wanted her to invite her again in life, but wait a minute, this is a good friend, I'm very fond of her, we can talk about it. And so we did. And she got this look of astonishment on her face and then, oh my god, she said, you know, I do that because that's how my mother doesn't, and that's how I've learned to do it.
我对此感到非常反感，以至于我发现自己当时在想，我真不确定以后还想不想再邀请她了，但等等，这是一个好朋友，我非常喜欢她，我们可以谈谈这件事。于是我们谈了。她脸上露出了惊讶的表情，然后说：“天哪，”她说，“你知道吗，我那样做是因为我妈妈就是这么做的，这也是我学到做事的方式。”
And she said, just happened last night. My mother prepared dinner. I got up and I kept helping. And she said, don't do that. Don't do that. don't do that. You're the guest. Stay seated. And I cleared the table and I washed the dishes and I cleaned up.
她还说：“就在昨晚发生的事。我妈妈准备了晚餐。我站起来不停地帮忙。”她说：“别那样做。别那样做。别那样做。你是客人。坐着别动。”然后我收拾了桌子，洗了盘子，打扫干净了。
And when I was done, my mother said, thank you so much for doing that. And it was a revelation to both of us. There are many people for whom the assumption is I'm going to offer to help. You're going to tell me you don't want me to, but you really do want me to. And in fact, it was another friend. We were both guests somewhere and she did that. And I said, could you do me a favor, ask the host the next day how she felt about that and she said, the host thanked her profusely. She said, I was so tired. There was no way I could have watched all those dishes myself. I was so grateful. And I heard her saying, no,
当我做完后，我妈妈说：“非常感谢你做这些。”这对我们俩来说都是一个启示。对许多人来说，他们的假设是：我会主动提出帮忙。你会告诉我你不需要，但你其实是希望我帮的。事实上，还有另一个朋友。我们俩当时都是某个地方的客人，她就这样做了。我说：“你能帮个忙吗，第二天问问主人她对此有何感觉，”她说，主人对她千恩万谢。她说：“我太累了。我根本不可能自己洗完所有那些盘子。我太感激了。”我听见她说：“不，
no, don't do it. Yeah. And the tricky thing that Deborah is if you had asked that host, you know, should I have helped, she may have well have told you, no, you don't have to help because she would have well told you no, you don't have to help, because she would have felt obliged to say that when in fact she did. This is what makes it so tricky that sometimes even doing the transparent thing of just asking the person, tell me what your conversational style is, even that does not elicit people's real conversational styles. You know, you were so right.
不，别做了。”是的。而棘手的事情在于，黛博拉，如果你去问那个主人，你知道的，我该帮忙吗，她很可能会告诉你，不，你不需要帮忙，因为她很可能会告诉你，不，你不需要帮忙，因为她会觉得有义务这么说，而实际上她的确需要。这就是让事情变得如此棘手的原因，有时甚至连直接询问对方“告诉我你的对话风格是什么”这种坦诚的做法，也无法引出人们真正的对话风格。你知道的，你太对了。
I was a guest at that dinner and I took the host at her word. When she said she didn't want help, I didn't help because that's how I prefer it. When I say I don't want help, I mean, and the term, again, this is from Gregory Bateson, meta-communicating. You talk about the communication. Metacommunicating often will work, but often it doesn't because people won't tell you. Think of a classic example of that. Someone suggests having lunch and you don't really want to. You don't say, are you kidding? I would never have lunch with you.
我是那场晚宴的客人，我把主人的一句话当真了。当她说她不需要帮忙时，我没有帮忙，因为我更喜欢这样。当我说我不需要帮忙时，我的意思是，这个词——再次说明，这来自格雷戈里·贝特森（Gregory Bateson）——元交流（meta-communicating）。你谈论的是交流本身。元交流通常会起作用，但往往不起作用，因为人们不会告诉你。想想这方面的一个经典例子。有人提议一起吃午饭，而你其实并不想去。你不会说：“开什么玩笑？我绝不会跟你一起吃午饭。”
You say, oh, you know, today's I have a lot of words today. I don't think I'll do it today. So they ask you again. And then you say, oh, you know, I'm kind of don't feel that well today. And so finally, they say, are these excuses real? Or should I stop asking? Because you really don't want to have lunch with me. You're still not going to say, no, I never want
你会说：“哦，你知道的，今天我有很多话要说。我觉得我今天就不去了。”于是他们再次邀请你。然后你说：“哦，你知道的，我今天感觉有点不太舒服。”最后，他们会说：“这些借口是真的吗？还是我应该别再问了？因为你真的不想和我吃午饭。”你仍然不会说：“不，我永远不想
to have lunch with you. You're probably going to get even more indirect. Oh, no, no, I really mean it. You're right. It is extremely difficult. Unless you have the kind of relationship where you have agreed, we both know there is this thing called conversational style. We both know these are things that can be tricky.
跟你吃午饭。”你可能会变得更加含蓄。“哦，不，不，我是认真的。”你说得对。这实在是极其困难。除非你们的关系已经达成一致：我们都知道有一种东西叫对话风格。我们都知道这些东西可能很棘手。
So let's agree that we're going to be as upfront about it as we can when asked. The same as understandings in professional settings can result in managers feeling disrespected or ignored, and employees feeling bullied or confused. One of the managers that was studying told me, he said, you know, when I make a decision, I just announce it, and I assume that if people aren't happy with it, they'll tell me, well, that's going to work for some people and not for others. So being aware of conversational style differences
所以让我们达成一致，在被问到时，我们要尽可能坦诚。职场中的误解可能会导致管理者感到不被尊重或被忽视，而员工则会感到被霸凌或困惑。我研究过的一位经理告诉我，他说：“你知道的，当我做出一个决定时，我只是宣布它，我假设如果人们对此不满意，他们会告诉我。”嗯，这招对某些人管用，对其他人则不然。因此，意识到对话风格的差异
is something that applies in every conversation. Yeah, and you can see in the workplace, a manager who tells a subordinate, you know, I'm wondering if you can do me a favor, can you get me an update on that report. In one situation, the employee can sort of say, this person is not flaunting their power, even though they could just simply tell me to go and get the update on the report. They're actually opening a conversation that sort of makes me feel included, but somebody else could say, you know, why is the boss talking like he's a pushover?
是适用于每一次对话的。是的，你可以在职场中看到，一个经理对下属说：“你知道的，我想知道你能不能帮我个忙，帮我弄一下那份报告的最新进展。”在某种情况下，员工可能会说，这个人并没有在炫耀他们的权力，尽管他们本可以简单地命令我去获取报告的最新进展。他们其实是在开启一段对话，这让我感到自己被包容了，但另一个人可能会说：“你知道的，为什么老板说话的样子像个软柿子？
Why can't he just simply tell me what he wants? And they're both perfectly legitimate ways of entering the conversation, but the ground rules need to be shared for the conversation to actually unfold successfully. I think power can be expressed and created either way. I was once told by a career naval officer. When he heard me talk about indirectness, he said, that's how the military works. I said, what? He said, when he was a midshipman, just in training and one of the officers teaching in class came to the class and he said, you know, it's cold
为什么他不能简单地告诉我他想要什么？”这两种都是完全合法的开启对话的方式，但为了让对话真正顺利展开，双方需要有共同的基本规则。我认为权力可以通过这两种方式来表达和创造。曾有一位海军职业军官告诉我。当他听到我谈论含蓄时，他说：“军队就是这样运作的。”我说：“什么？”他说，当他是一名海军见习生，正处于训练阶段时，一位在课堂上授课的军官来到班里说：“这里很冷
in here and everybody nodded and he said, young men was men at the time. When I say something, I expect you to do something about it. So let's try that again. It's cold in here. And the officer was telling me this story, he said, and we all jumped up and went to close the windows, and that was a lesson we had learned that served just extremely well in the military. It was because of the power that he had the privilege of being indirect. What makes all of this even more difficult is that the interplay of conversational styles
。”大家都点头。他说：“年轻人——当时都是男的——当我说话时，我期望你们做点什么。所以我们再试一次。这里很冷。”讲到这个故事时，这位军官说：“我们都跳起来去关窗户，这是我们在军队中学到的一课，对我们极其有用。”正因为他拥有权力，他才享有含蓄的特权。这一切之所以更加困难，是因为对话风格的相互交织
changes from person to person. Debra, as a fast-talking New Yorker, learned she had to force herself not to jump in every time there was a pause in conversations she had with one colleague. I had to learn to count to seven before I thought he had nothing to say. His name was Ron Scullin, he was from the Midwest. He was married to Suzie Scullin who was Chinese from Hawaii and when he talked to Suie, he was the one who kept interrupting, and she would say, you ask me a question, and you don't give me time to answer, you're asking another one. He and Susie did research in Alaska among Athabaskan Indians. Susie was constantly interrupting the Athabascans, because their sense of pauses were longer than hers. So I like that example because it really drives home. We're not talking about
因人而异。黛博拉作为一个语速极快的纽约人，她发现自己必须强迫自己，在与某位同事的对话中，每当出现停顿就不去插话。“我不得不学会数到七，才认为他无话可说了。”他的名字叫罗恩·斯库林（Ron Scullin），来自中西部。他娶了苏茜·斯库林（Suzy Scullin），一个来自夏威夷的中国人，当他和苏茜交谈时，他反倒成了那个不断打断别人的人，而苏茜会说：“你问了我一个问题，却不给我时间回答，你又问了另一个。”他和苏茜在阿拉斯加的阿萨巴斯卡印第安人（Athabaskan Indians）中间做过研究。苏茜经常打断阿萨巴斯卡人，因为他们对停顿的感知比她更长。所以我喜欢这个例子，因为它真正地阐明了：我们谈论的不是
absolutes. You talk fast, you talk slow, it's always relative. When we come back, how to learn to code switch across the chasms of cross-cultural communication. You'll listen to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We've seen how different conversational styles can produce unintended conflict and misunderstanding. Linguist Deborah Tannen's more recent work has focused on the land mines buried in conversations between siblings, between parents and children, and between political adversaries. In all these realms, she finds that much animosity and conflict could be reduced if we only stop to do what her parents did during her childhood or what she did during her PhD dissertation.
绝对值。你说得快，你说得慢，这总是相对的。当我们回来时，如何学习在跨文化沟通的鸿沟中进行语码转换。你在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们已经看到，不同的对话风格会产生意想不到的冲突和误解。语言学家黛博拉·坦宁更近期的工作聚焦于埋藏在兄弟姐妹之间、父母与孩子之间以及政治对手之间对话中的地雷。在所有这些领域中，她发现，如果我们能停下来去做她父母在她童年时做过的事，或者她做博士论文时做过的事，那么许多敌意和冲突都可以减少。
Step back from conversations and analyze them like a scientist. This is often very hard to do in real life because when people say things that upset us, we rarely stop to think. Deborah, after you started getting famous and went on TV all the time, your mom noticed something about your TV appearances. What was it? My mother was very upset that I was wearing the same red jacket on all the TV shows. She just complained. Of course, my mother was the only one who watched every show that I was on. At that time, it was every city you went to, you did a show. And so I had
从对话中退后一步，像科学家一样去分析它们。在现实生活中这通常很难做到，因为当人们说出让我们心烦意乱的话时，我们很少停下来思考。黛博拉，在你开始变得出名并频频上电视之后，你妈妈对你在电视上的露面注意到了一点。是什么？我妈妈对我在所有电视节目中都穿着同一件红夹克感到非常沮丧。她一直在抱怨。当然，我妈妈是唯一一个看我上过的每一个节目的人。当时，你去的每一个城市，都要做一个节目。所以我有
the jacket I was wearing on my book tour. But then she would watch them all back to back. And really upset her. My mother always felt that I paid insufficient attention to my clothes. I have to mention one thing, since your mom is not here to observe the conversation, I have to flag the fact that you are wearing a red jacket for this conversation today. No, it's just a red-chill neck. But I do like to wear red, it's true. And what was your reaction when your mom basically told you after you had finished this triumph in Book Tour, why are you wearing the same jacket all the time?
我在图书巡回路演时穿的那件夹克。但她会把它们连着看好几集。这真的让她很抓狂。我妈妈一直觉得我对自己的衣服不够关注。我必须提一件事，既然你妈妈不在这里观察这场对话，我必须指出这样一个事实：你今天为了这场对话也穿了一件红夹克。不，这只是一个红色的衣领。但我确实喜欢穿红色，这是真的。当你妈妈在图书巡回签售取得巨大成功后对你说“为什么你总是穿同一件夹克”时，你的反应是什么？
What was your reaction, Deborah? I was, of course, heard that she was talking about what I was wearing and not what I said. And I remember discussing this with the host on one of the National Morning shows. She told me that her mother did that, that her mother would tell her after each morning what was wrong with what she was wearing, or maybe what was wrong with her hair. The kind of interaction Deborah had with her mother has long been a staple of television comedy. In Vipe, Julia Louis Dreyfus plays a politician and a mom. In one episode, her daughter reaches out where the heart felt plea.
你的反应是什么，黛博拉？我当然感到受伤，因为她在意的是我穿什么，而不是我说什么。我记得曾在一家全国性早间节目的主持人的节目上讨论过这件事。她告诉我，她的母亲也会这样，她的母亲会在每天早晨结束后告诉她，她穿的衣服有什么不对劲，或者也许是她的头发有什么不对劲。黛博拉与她母亲的这种互动一直是电视喜剧的核心要素。在《副总统》中，朱莉娅·路易斯-德利法斯（Julia Louis Dreyfus）饰演一位政客兼母亲。在其中一集里，她的女儿带着诚挚的恳求找到她。
I have had a hard, lonely, miserable life, and the only thing that is going to make it worthwhile is if I become the daughter of the next president of the United States. Okay, sweetie, thanks. And that jacket doesn't work. By the way, you look like a waiter. Oh, God. Damn it. Deborah writes about what she calls the big three flashpoints in conflicts between mothers
我过着艰难、孤独、悲惨的生活，唯一能让这一切变得值得的事情，就是我成为下一任美国总统的女儿。好吧，甜心，谢谢。还有，那件夹克不合适。顺便说一句，你看起来像个服务员。哦，天哪。该死。黛博拉写到了她所谓的母女冲突中的三大导火索：
and daughters. Hair, clothes, and weight. And the mother-daughter relationship in some ways is a perfect storm. From the point of view of the daughter, here's the person you most want to think you're perfect. You think she knows you so well, and if she thinks you're wanting, then you really must be fatally flawed. From the point of view of the mother, here's the person you most want to help
头发、衣服和体重。从某种程度上说，母女关系是一场完美风暴。从女儿的角度来看，这是你最希望认为自己是完美的那个人。你觉得她非常了解你，如果她认为你不够完美，那你一定是有致命的缺陷。从母亲的角度来看，这是你最想要帮助的那个人，
to make sure everything goes as well as it could for her. And women are judged by appearance, hair and clothes and weight. So, from the point of view of the mother, this is caring. I just want to make sure everything goes well for you. Nobody else will tell you because they don't love you as much as I do. They don't care as much as I do. But anytime you make a suggestion for improvement, you are implying criticism. And that's what the daughters here. So in fact, my mother's critical is one of the biggest complaints I heard from adult daughters
以确保她的一切都尽可能顺利。而女性是以容貌、头发、衣服和体重来评判的。所以，从母亲的角度来看，这是关心。我只是想确保你一切顺利。别人不会告诉你，因为他们不像我这么爱你。他们不像我这么在乎你。但每当你提出改进的建议时，你就是在暗示批评。这就是女儿们听到的。事实上，我从成年女儿那里听到最大的抱怨之一就是“我妈妈很挑剔”，而我从成年女儿的母亲那里听到最大的抱怨之一也是“我一张嘴，她就把一切都当作批评”。
and one of the biggest complaints I heard from mothers of adult daughters was, I can't open my mouth. She takes everything as criticism. And it's both. It's not who's right, who's wrong. It's that suggestions for improvement really are implied criticism and are also a sign of caring. I understand that one time your mom asked you about your hair. Yes.
两者兼而有之。这不是谁对谁错的问题。而是改进的建议确实暗示了批评，同时也表现出了关怀。我听说有一次你妈妈问起你的头发。是的。
Tell me about that. I was visiting my mother and she said, do you like your hair that long? And I burst out laughing. And she asked why. And I said, well, you know, I'm writing this book about mothers and daughters. And so many daughters tell me their mothers are critical of their hair.
跟我讲讲那个。我当时去看望我母亲，她说：“你喜欢这么长的头发吗？”我突然大笑起来。她问为什么。我说：“嗯，你知道的，我正在写一本关于母女的书。很多女儿告诉我，她们的母亲对她们的头发很挑剔。”
And she said, I wasn't criticizing. So I let it drop. And then later in the visit, I said, so mom, what do you think of my hair? And she said, I think it's a little too long. Now, I was doing this one woman who said to me, she was in her 60s and so her mother would have been in her 80s and she said, my mother's losing her eyesight. But she can still spot a pimple across the room. Now, that was said in the spirit of my mother's going to
她说：“我不是在批评。”所以我没再提这事。后来在探望期间，我说：“妈妈，你觉得我的头发怎么样？”她说：“我觉得有点太长了。”现在，我遇到过一个60多岁的女性，所以她的母亲应该80多岁了，她说：“我妈妈视力在下降。但她依然能在房间的另一头发现一颗青春痘。”这句话的用意是：我妈妈会
find my flaw, the one thing, the one flaw. Now, who, when they look at you, is going to see the pimple yourself. Right. And mothers and daughters often look at each other as reflections of themselves. And therefore, with the same level of scrutiny to which they subject themselves. And we touched on this earlier in our conversation. All of these categories are going to be influenced by class, by culture, by nationality in all kinds of interesting ways. They might be cultures where moms are expressing their concerns in terms of how their daughters are not eating enough,
找出我的缺点，那一件事，唯一的缺点。现在，有谁在看着你时，会自己发现那颗青春痘呢？对吧。而母女俩常常把彼此看作是自己的倒影。因此，她们会以审视自己的那种挑剔程度来审视对方。我们在前面的对话中也提到了这一点。所有这些类别都将以各种有趣的方式受到阶级、文化、国籍的影响。可能会有这样一些文化：母亲们表达担忧的方式是担心女儿吃得不够多，
not that they're eating too much. I mean, so a lot of this is culturally specific. Not necessarily that all mothers and all daughters in all cultures behave exactly the same way. Yeah, well, the specifics may be different. And by the way, I have been told by some women, my mother never did that, my mother never criticized. So all these things are not everybody, not 100 percent, but the pattern seemed to be pretty cross-cultural. So, for example, a woman from Oman told me that mothers there might say to their daughters, I can see hair, meaning
而不是担心她们吃得太多。我的意思是，很多这方面的内容是特定于文化的。并不一定意味着所有文化中的所有母亲和所有女儿的行为方式都完全一样。是的，具体细节可能会有所不同。顺便说一句，有些女性告诉我：我妈妈从不那样做，我妈妈从不挑剔。所以所有这些事情并不是适用于所有人，不是100%，但这种模式似乎具有相当强的跨文化性。所以，例如，一位来自阿曼的女性告诉我，那里的母亲可能会对女儿说：“我能看到头发，”意思是
your hijab isn't completely covering your hair. Or a woman told me, this is from Africa, she had a wedding, she was gonna go to, she showed her mother the dress, she was planning to wear for the wedding. The mother made a comment that she didn't think it was appropriate, and so the daughter stayed up the whole night sewing a new dress for the wedding. Wow. So the specifics may be different,
你的头巾没有完全遮住头发。或者一位女性告诉我，这是来自非洲的，她要参加一个婚礼，她把她打算在婚礼上穿的裙子拿给她母亲看。母亲评论说她觉得这不合适，于是女儿通宵缝制了一件新裙子去参加婚礼。哇。所以具体细节可能会有所不同，
but the mother being the guardian of the daughter's appearance, because women are judged by appearance. As I read your work, Debra, I was struck by how naively many of us enter conversations. You know, we think conversations are, you know, like a walk in the park. When really it's often, you know, potentially a walk across a minefield. And the fact that we're naïve about the challenges is actually one of the dangers. We this is why we never expected when things blow up in our faces. Yes, and this is partly why it's so satisfying when it goes well. There are so many things that could misfire the pace at which you speak,
但母亲是女儿外表的守护者，因为女性是以容貌来评判的。当我阅读你的作品时，黛博拉，我被我们许多人天真地进入对话的方式震惊了。你知道的，我们认为对话就像是在公园里散步一样。而实际上它通常（你知道的）可能是在雷区中穿行。我们对其中的挑战表现得天真，其实正是危险之一。这就是为什么当事情在我们面前搞砸时我们从不曾预料到。是的，这也是为什么当事情进展顺利时会如此令人满意的原因。有太多事情可能会偏离轨道：你说话的节奏，
not just how long you wait between turns, but how quickly, within turns, how you get to the point. Do you get right to the point or do you start kind of vague so that if you're talking to someone who doesn't work that way, they cut you off before you get to the point, because they think you've had a chance. The rhythms, the music of speech, the intonation patterns, humor. That is a mind field. What can you tell jokes about?
不仅是你轮流发言之间等待多久，还有在发言内部你有多快，你是如何切入正点的。你是直奔主题还是从某种含糊不清的话开始，这样如果你在和一个不按这种方式行事的人说话，他们在你切入正点之前就把你打断了，因为他们觉得你已经有机会了。节奏、言语的音乐、语调模式、幽默。那是一个雷区。你可以拿什么开玩笑？
How do you let people know that you're joking and that you're teasing? I'm wondering, Deborah, if one of the solutions that might be called for is in some ways for all of us to exercise both a little more empathy, but also a little more compassion for one another. In other words, to start with the assumption that misunderstandings are happening because of unintended signals. In other words, to extend to the other people in our lives, whether those are work colleagues or people in our personal lives,
你如何让别人知道你在开玩笑、你在逗弄？我在想，黛博拉，可能需要的一种解决方案是，在某种程度上，我们所有人都对彼此多一点同理心，同时也多一点同情心。换句话说，从这样的假设开始：误解的发生是因为无意中发出的信号。换句话说，向我们生活中的其他人（无论是同事还是我们个人生活中的人）传达这样一点：
that if a misunderstanding has occurred, odds are, it's probably happened because of a miscommunication, not because someone intended to hurt us. That's a great way to look at it. I often say mine is a rhetoric of good intentions. And people sometimes object to my work. They say, well, what if people don't mean well? What if they really are out to get you? What if they really are hostile? And my response is, that's not news. People are always ready to see other people that's having bad intentions and being up to no good,
如果发生了误解，大概率是因为沟通不畅，而不是因为有人故意伤害我们。这是一个很好的看待方式。我经常说我的是“善意修辞学”。人们有时会反对我的作品。他们会说：“嗯，如果人们不是出于善意呢？如果他们真的是冲着你来的呢？如果他们真的很敌对呢？”我的回应是：“这算不上什么新鲜事。人们总是准备好把别人看作是怀有恶意、居心不良，
or having bad personality characteristics. So the news that my work can provide is to step back and think what if they don't have that intentions but have different conversational style, different ways of trying to accomplish the positive things they're trying to accomplish. And what's thinking about conversational style does is give you a way to imagine different intentions. Yeah. We had the actor and writer Alan Alda on Hidden Brain a couple of years ago And he said something that was very insightful. It's possible of course that if we imagine that other people are not trying to harm us
或者具有不良人格特征。”所以我这项工作能提供的新视角是，退后一步去思考：如果他们不是心怀恶意，而是有不同的对话风格、有不同的方式去试图实现他们正努力达成的积极目标呢？思考对话风格能做到的，是为你提供了一种去想象不同意图的方法。是的。几年前，我们在《隐藏的大脑》节目中采访了演员兼作家阿兰·阿尔达（Alan Alda），
We could be wrong in fact. They might actually be out to get us and we could be naive about it But but he said the more empathy I have for other people the less annoying I find that they are the way I have for other people, the less annoying I find that they are. You know, it's separate from the fact that whatever people's real intentions might be, it might actually be just be better for us to show my empathy, because we'll end up being less triggered by other people. I love that perspective, absolutely. If you frame everything as a fight, it's corrosive to the human spirit. Everyone feels less safe and more vulnerable.
他说了一些非常有洞察力的话。当然，如果我们想象其他人不是在试图伤害我们，我们也有可能是错的。事实上，他们可能真的是在针对我们，而我们可能对此很天真。但是他说，我对其他人的同理心越多，我发现他们就越不烦人，我对其他人的同理心越多，我发现他们就越不烦人。你知道的，撇开人们真正的意图可能是什么不谈，对我们来说，表现出同理心实际上可能更好，因为我们最终受其他人触发的负面情绪会更少。我非常喜欢这个视角，绝对如此。如果你把每件事都当作一场争斗，这对人类精神是有侵蚀性的。每个人都会感到更缺乏安全感、更脆弱。
If you get in the habit of seeing good intentions, yeah, maybe you'll miss a few bad intentions and think better of a few people that don't deserve it. But the world will feel like a safer place, whether you're right or not. But I think you'll be right more often than you realize. Deborah Tannen is a linguist at Georgetown University. Her books include That's not what I meant. You just don't understand women and men in conversation
如果你养成看到善意的习惯，是的，也许你会漏掉一些恶意，对几个不配得到好意的人看法好一些。但无论你猜得对不对，世界都会感觉是一个更安全的地方。但我认为，你会比自己意识到的更经常猜对。黛博拉·坦宁是乔治城大学的语言学家。她的著作包括《那不是我的意思》、《你就是不懂：男女对话》
and you're wearing that, understanding mothers and daughters in conversation. Her most recent book is Finding My Father. Deborah, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, it's really been a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Ben Riscan. Ben is a
以及《你穿成这样？理解母女对话》。她最近的一本著作是《寻找我的父亲》。黛博拉，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，这真是一段愉快的时光。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保尔（Annie Murphy-Paul）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是本·里斯坎（Ben Riscan）。本是
co-founder of Room Tone, a consulting firm that provides strategic and managerial support to podcasters. Ben is someone who seems to know everyone in the audio field, and even better, he enjoys making connections between people who have shared interest. Since we launched our independent production company in 2020, we've greatly enjoyed chatting with Ben and hearing his insights on where the podcasting industry is headed. Thank you, Ben. If you missed any of the episodes from our Mindreading 2.0 series, please be sure to go back and check them out. For more of our work, subscribe to the Hidden Brain newsletter.
Room Tone的联合创始人，这是一家为播客提供战略和管理支持的咨询公司。本似乎是那种认识音频领域所有人的人，更好的是，他喜欢在有共同兴趣的人之间建立联系。自从我们在2020年成立独立的制作公司以来，我们非常高兴能与本聊天，并听取他对播客行业发展方向的见解。谢谢你，本。如果你错过了我们“读心术2.0”系列的任何一集，请务必返回去收看。想要了解我们的更多作品，请订阅《隐藏的大脑》时事通讯。
You can sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that site is newsneWS-E-W-S dot hiddenbrain dot org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 注册。再次说明，网址是 news dot hiddenbrain dot org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。